this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at the weapons
from our recent poll winner Titanfall 2.
I'm looking right now at several 20
millimeter cannon systems and I can't
really show you those very easily
however I can show you this just
and of course make sure to subscribe for
more of this kind of content on the
channel including Loadout which takes an
in-depth look at some of the most iconic
firearms in gaming right let's take a
look at the weapons of Titanfall 2.
all right so this this thing looks at
first glance like a short compact
carbine assault rifle if you like in
terms of the size of the magazine well
and what turns out to be the base plate
of the magazine but
when in use it is clearly a submachine
gun it's spitting out little pistol
cases nicely modeled by the way complete
with uh dimple primers and you can see
the magazine is actually somewhat short
front to back and the big chunky bit on
the bottom is a base plate so obviously
we don't have a gun like this in the
collection but a relatively recent
acquisition for us is this BNT APC 9
which does have
a very deep
magazine well but it is in fact solid
all the way around and is designed to
take a nine millimeter magazine so this
is one of the closest things we would
have to this this gun has sci-fi thumb
hole stock syndrome
which is not ideal for for most purposes
you'll see thumb hole stocks on
Precision rifles some of the time having
a a rigid stock is more important than
being able to quickly grasp the pistol
grip but it's a very quick way to make
your gun look futuristic I think
the ejection on this is a bit crazy so
it's not very energetic and as the
weapons counted over magically the case
ejection is kind of trickling off over
to the left whereas it should just well
at that angle it should be probably
coming out vertically you needed a
little force behind case ejection
otherwise the gun will tend to stop so
it's kind of odd that the pattern of
rejection is changing that drastically
just from tilting the weapon over
because it instead of going out straight
to the side or at an angle to the side
it should just be going out
like that these are the kind of silly
details that I tend to notice
now normally if I if I'm talking about
Mac Weaponry stuff that's you know
massive and carried by some sort of
armored suit or robot or something it's
pretty difficult because although we do
have that sort of stuff in the
collection or at least vehicle and
aircraft parallels to it and I can't
really show you those very easily
however
I'll show you this
this is a Soviet era ags-17
it is semi-automatic just like the canon
in this it's not dissimilar in profile
this is obviously a lot smaller than the
gun depicted it fires 30 millimeter
grenades they don't look quite like the
big 40 mil artillery rounds on this
thing but hey this is the biggest thing
I can possibly hold up for you in front
of the camera
um and it's it's pretty cool it has a
sort of rip the cord cocking system on
the back there and then a firing plate
for the thumbs and it chugs away at a
low rate of fire and a significant Arc
it's a direct fire weapon as we see in
the game here but it's also used at
extreme angles of elevation now we also
have a bit on the feed side of things as
well because this is belt fed
and I definitely can't hold up both of
these attached to each other but it's
the right side of the gun I was just
holding Clips this and it is a
a belt box these are drill rounds these
are solid brass where they show you the
sort of size and shape
of 30 millimeter grenade rounds that
this thing actually fires so we have a
length of this
this isn't even full this would be
tremendously heavy but this is a crew
served weapon what's missing is the
tripod so we don't have a giant Mac suit
um but we do have the tripod that this
Clips onto
so I thought you might find that fun
I know I did
I don't know if I'm being trolled here
but um em4
and the words Cold War and the general
bull puppiness of this thing make me
think
someone someone riffing on the em2 I
can't help but recognize the general
shape of the of the carrying handle site
rail as being pretty similar to the real
one on the em2 albeit much bigger but
it's very far removed from from the real
bm2
let's have a look at it
well I couldn't resist I had to go and
get the gun I'm thinking of
so although I have a load of EMTs behind
me they're not equipped with this
variance carry handle
that has well it's bigger and squarer a
bit like the one on this gun and it has
this adjustment
drum on the rear so this is this is what
I'm thinking of without this three and a
half pass uh sniper
scope that's on this particular gun that
plus plus the Bullpup shape and the name
perhaps the developers can let us know
is there any inspiration or is it just a
sheer coincidence I have to believe that
there's some some inspiration there
this is nice to see so we have shared
weapons technology between the two games
um well two franchises Titanfall and
Apex Legends I'm sure a lot of you are
aware clear relationship between the
two-barreled version which has a real
world parallel believe it or not in the
corabov design from the Cold War era in
the Soviet Union but it's nice to see
the the consistent design Aesthetics of
these two two barrel versus three barrel
and in this fictional Universe you've
got the option you fire two shots at
once you can fire free the obvious
downside even of a two barrel system is
weight weight and bulk inevitably we've
effectively welded two guns together you
know in a real world we have product
ranges that do different things and
fulfill different roles military law
enforcement civilian and game universes
like this are developing their own with
their own fictional manufacturers and
their own classes of weapon
Loosely based on reality and then their
own types as well and perhaps change
over time as well it's fascinating to
follow
um doing what I do
another shared Universe gun here we've
got there's a v47 and a vk-47 and they
are different in-game models that they
almost look like ones improved from the
other I think that's probably the idea
but the overall configuration is well
it's taken akm chop it into bits and
stick it back together without reference
to a photograph and you have you have
these that's about to be unfair it's
it's quite a cool design the thing I
remember from looking at the other
version of it was the selector now this
is not a Bullpup akm which is pretty
much what these guys are this is the
somewhat well known although
only if you're into this stuff groza
um which is a 9x39 caliber
short barrel rifle effects of real
assault rifle with a grenade launcher
integrated into the system as well you
can still see the aspects of the akm as
you can on this gun so we still have an
akm slash AK-74 style top cover here
because the gas system under here is
basically the same as the AK there's an
AK star pistol grip whereas the gp30
grenade launcher this is based on has a
little stubby one to get it out of the
way as a rifle and a barrel launcher
this has got the full-size AK-74 rifle
pistol grip funnily enough the in-game
gun has a thumb hole stock Arrangement
so it doesn't have that bit of AK
recognition but there's enough going on
with the two hand guards that are
obviously wood or brown plastic that
makes your brain think okay there is a
gas tube type thing visible the top
cover at the back as on the groza is
recognizably AK I think and
the selector thing at the back so safety
selector is very okay as well on this
but as I remember from last time for
some reason on this fictional gun it is
upside down and back to front it's
pretty it's actually pretty far removed
from AK but there are enough
vestigial remains to make you think this
is a bit like a collection of God all
right we've got another nice
side-by-side comparison of the two
variants here every detail is actually
different so it's been sort of retcon
reimagined as well as also being
upgraded the Apex Legends version just
looks more futuristic to me
foreign
I think if you're going to do super
sci-fi lmg that's probably the way to do
it it's significantly different than
it's not just like Mini Me In Space it's
very compact it's got some bizarre heat
based reloading effectively reloading
system so it's like an energy weapon
that relies on overheating to constrain
your effective rate of fire and then
you're sort of fixing it when it hasn't
when it overheats so if you can manage
the heat successfully but like with an
old-fashioned FPS turret weapon or
something good example of the niche of
an lmg in sort of FPS language but
really isn't anything like what we have
today
um sometimes it's nice to have
futuristic riffs on what you know but I
tend in general terms to prefer
something completely different if we're
looking at a far future setting
very very chunky construction which
you'd expect for something that has to
be carried by a giant robot essentially
I like the detailing on it though the
warning labels are always fun so we've
got sort of Hazard tape caution it's
funny that there's a warning saying stay
back 20 meters and yet the case ejection
is basically straight up
so you can stay back 20 meters all you
like but I'm going to be landing on your
head
if your vehicle essentially this is a
vehicle has to just go through the
motions of operating and loading a gun
like a normal person that's a bit
redundant
um on the plus side it means they can
pick up any weapon on the battlefield
and in the sort of ecosystem of
Titanfall
we know that there are weapons lying
around that you could pick up and use
however from what I remember playing the
game that doesn't factor in you are
stuck with the weapon that you equip it
fits with the whole the mech is a
character in its own right thing for
them to pick up and use weapons but it
it's problematic in Practical terms but
why am I talking about practicality when
we're talking about bipedal armored
Fighting Machines
yeah
hmm so I was going to comment on the
fact that this thing's called the mgl
and is a sort of infantry grenade
launcher like the milk or mgl is
um but but they're completely different
they're actually not so different
because although it's got a box and a
belt belt appears to be a fixed Loop and
so the rounds are being fired and then
I'll still call it a belt but it's
acting more like a cylinder is rotating
within the box so really taking
advantage of the setting we have the the
grenades for assume they're 40
millimeter not sure and they will bounce
off human players Pilots or whatever
still explode and do damage but it's
very clear that they are also being
magnetically attracted to metallic
enemies and therefore they're going to
do more more Focus damage because
they're stuck to them good way to change
things up it's a it's recognizable it's
intuitive you know how to use it and you
get the cool factor of a rotary grenade
launcher but then you get something
additional as well
it is it's a Sci-Fi Gatling gun what can
I say there's a slightly weird charger
style alt attack where it's like a one
powerful shot instead of the normal
Gatling slash chain gun burst of fire or
continuous burst fire where it looks
like all the barrels are firing at once
if this works like a Gatling gun which
it appears to then
it's a rotating breach system where you
can only ever fire one barrel after the
other you would not be able to fly them
all at once because they're not all
chambered at once
it's the future so
um you have that other option
let's have the distinctive thing about
the this this R series as it turns out
there's a series of these assault rifles
the distinctive design feature is that
very raked forward magazine housing and
very long magazine housing which I
suspect I've probably mentioned before
is inspired by the Chris Factor
otherwise it's very much the same as as
the other one that's not a bad thing I
might have swapped them around and had
them all sort of Scar looking
conventional what what is it what is the
SMG I might swap that around and had the
the r series guns be the SMGs but who
cares um they do they fit the niches for
absolutely fine ones one sort of pistol
caliber one is like assault rifle
caliber
more than any other Titan weapon that I
remember or have seen in in this footage
this thing really comes off as a
handheld artillery piece with the way
the breach opens and the the empty case
comes punching out the back of the gun
effect wise it's pretty unusual
um not quite a gun and it's not quite a
flamethrower and it's using um I'm sure
you know this real world compound
thermite and so it's got a shell and
when it lands the the content that burns
whatever it's sat on and I'm sure you're
sitting like me you probably watch
videos of thermite burning through
engine blocks and stuff it's it's
seriously impressive slightly scary
stuff so I like the idea of using it as
a as a game weapon like this so it's
sort of flamethrower adjacent but is
much more gun like
I always like the idea of the smart
pistol I think because of fifth element
with the the zorg zf1 and the idea of
picking a Target and wherever you shoot
all of your shots go to it I think my
only reservation I had with it was and
is
the fact that it's a pistol right if the
pistol can do that why can't any of the
other Small Arms do it because they're
real estate as it were on a on a handgun
for building in that kind of technology
is way less than on a rifle or something
so and I know that I know the answer
it's a gameplay it's a very cool idea
and it is a different style of gameplay
and I guess the fact that it's a pistol
fits with the whole wall running parkour
aspect of being a pilot design wise it's
fairly conventional it sort of looks a
bit like a slightly space-age race gun I
suppose it's like wall running John Wick
when you use the smart pistol
there's more variety to the Titan
weapons than I remember in this game
this looks like a rotary grenade
launcher like me like the mgl functions
similarly as well but um three barrels
so I assume that the like three rounds
in in the drum are aligning and firing
at the same time the curvature would
seem to not match up with three flat
barrels but it must do but it's not a
grenade launcher it's
um solid shot essentially so it's like a
I mean there are rotary as we know there
are rotary shotguns as well and if you
load those with slug then you'd have
something similar to this only make it
10 times bigger and find a robot suit
those were the guns of Titanfall 2. hope
you enjoyed those
um always interested in that in that
franchise in that world
I hope you'll join us over on the Royal
armories YouTube channel if you haven't
already we have some interesting stuff
going on over there not just Firearms
quite a lot of that as well various
social media Outlets attached to us as
well and of course our three museums if
you're able to come and visit us please
do but we will see you either way next
time here on this channel